[Music]
when I was a kid the greatest thing
imaginable for me was the moonshot
President John F Kennedy said to the US
Congress in May 1961 I believe this
country should commit itself to the goal
before the decade is out of landing a
man on the moon and returning him safely
to the earth well how cool was that
and President Kennedy's vision not only
rallied the country but was fulfilled
when Neil Armstrong walked on the moon
in the summer of 1969 in our time we've
had a different kind of moonshot in my
opinion and that is the moonshot to make
our world safe fair and sustainable and
Kofi Annan then secretary-general of the
United Nations in the year 2000 a great
man at the start of the new millennium
said to the world leaders let's also
take a goal a goal to fight global
poverty and wrestle it down to size and
he put on the agenda of the world the
Millennium Development Goals these were
adopted in a summit of the heads of
state in the year 2000 and they said
let's get extreme poverty the kind of
poverty that kills let's get that down
at least by half by the Year 2015
well despite all the noise in the world
and the uncaring and the distractions
and the confusion and the war in Iraq
and all the rest there was some focus
finally on this kind of moonshot in our
time of fighting extreme poverty and
major initiatives were undertaken for
example establishing the Global Fund to
fight AIDS TB and malaria and those
diseases started to really get under
control for the first time
big successes even in a distracted and
confused world well fast forward 12
years after those Millennium Development
Goals were adopted to 2012
yet again world leaders came together on
the anniversary of the Earth Summit
which had been a 1992 meeting to try to
tackle climate change environmental
crisis and so on in Rio de Janeiro 20
years later when governments got
together again they looked and they said
mmm we're not doing very well
climate change is running out of control
we're destroying other species we're
chopping down the Amazon you look around
we've got serious problems at that point
one of the government's the government
of Colombia had a really bright idea and
the Colombian government noted look the
Millennium Development Goals are making
progress against poverty why don't we
have a set of goals that builds on that
to achieve sustainable development what
did they mean by that what does even
sustainable development mean what it
means is that we want a world that is
prosperous but also fair and
environmentally sustainable where we're
not destroying ourselves with
human-induced global warming and
destroying other species and polluting
to the extent that millions of people
die prematurely every year because of
air and water pollution and wrecking our
oceans as well so in 2012 the government
said looking at the Millennium Goals and
their progress let's take the period
after 2015 to 2030 to get finally the
world on track to achieve sustainable
development that is a world of
prosperity social justice and
environmental sustainability and lo and
behold they negotiated they adopted
goals and targets and on September 25th
twenty
1593 governments of the United Nations
by acclamation following a marvelous
speech by Pope Francis in the chamber of
the UN General Assembly adopted the
sustainable development goals these are
the world's agreed objectives for the
year 2030 to end extreme poverty and
hunger get every kid in school ensure
universal health coverage fight for
gender equality reduce inequalities of
income and wealth control climate change
and stop the destruction of biodiversity
pretty cool for me it's our moonshot
it's phenomenal
compared to the foolishness of most of
what our government does these days
wouldn't it be wonderful if we were
actually solving problems and that's the
idea of the sustainable development
goals let's get something done politics
is not a game of one fool trying to hold
power against another fool or how much
money can you throw in so that you can
buy your congressmen or senators so
they'll vote for your tax cuts so that
you can have the ex kazillion dollars
rather than only why gazillion dollars
which is what American politics is about
right now but rather why don't we make a
21st century that is smart fair and
sustainable so I really recommend the
SDGs I recommend everybody learn them
see them understand them every part of
society can play a role I'm an academic
I believe universities get in there help
solve these problems show what can be
done businesses how do we align with
sustainability not sell cruddy products
that wreck the planet but good ones that
can sustain the planet
churches communities congregations
cities how do we get organized to be
smart fair and sustainable rather than
wrecking the planet and pervading
unfairness this is a job for everybody
so I call it our generations moonshot
and I strongly recommend them
[Music]
you